the cinema of lien Evert Mueller to me
is the cinema of seduction
I learned the name lien Evert Miller
before I had seen her films I was
enamored even by the sound of her name I
said it to myself seven times like an
incantation in retrospect maybe it was
the first film I saw of hers was swept
away and I was just that it was
beautiful and funny and wicked and
musical and sexy and grand I wanted more
I watched everything I ate her films
like a character of hers would gorge on
food or alcohol or talking or sex her
films turned me into an addict
I loved how everything about her films
were too much and at the same time
utterly truthful her characters don't
exaggerate they externalized the vivid
emotions of being human her filmmaking
his personal specific idiosyncratic but
also global cinema in the truest sense
they are epic and they take place on a
vast stage which translates to viewers
around the world her movies deserve to
be 30 feet tall the fact that she is a
woman is both central and secondary
she's a feminist filmmaker but not
because her characters fall into
lockstep with the didactic she doesn't
serve any one ideology she always seems
interested in breaking a rule or the
minute you think you can classify her
one way she moves the other way her
feminism feminism isn't dry it's naughty
and it's playful she's on high as an
artist but as a human being she's an
Earthbound body saint of cinema I'm in
awe of her as a woman as a trailblazer
and a godmother to us all but above all
as an out-and-out great filmmaker thank
you
good evening everyone buona sera
Leena I have been asked to speak on the
history of women and the directing
category and the Academy it's a very
short history more of a haiku
first there was Lena for more are
nominated than Katherine one so the
number of nominations for women 5 for
the men it's a different story
the number of Best Director nominations
but 60 70 80 are no hundred hundred
twenty and thirty forty hundred fifty
hundred and sixty hundred 70 180 190 200
210 230 240 250 260 270 280 290 300
still goes on 310 320 330 340 350 and 70
Oscar's staggeringly unequal the first
and last time a woman experiences true
equality is at birth the moment when the
doctors or nurses or midwives catch the
newborn and it's a girl or it's a boy
after that equality for women steeply
descends especially and remarkably in
this industry so I mean how do you
correct centuries of patriarchal
domination well at the academy that
began with the genius of Lena work
Miller everywhere
everywhere in her cinema and
particularly so in her masterwork seven
beauties the hero of seven beauties
Pasqualino is a handsome Neapolitan a
dandy a bullied to his seven sisters a
baby to his mama a liar seducer a
self-serving tough hearted sentimental
creep murderer rapist yet Jean colored
Jionni's Pasqualino is disconcertingly
magnetic the thorns narrative defies
expectations it has Pasqualino and a
fellow deserter captured and imprisoned
in a Nazi death camp then returns to
Naples to tell the story of how
Pasqualino arrived in Germany and how he
intends surviving the death camp by
seducing the female commandant a
dead-eyed blond monster
what follows is the most pathetic
hilarious tragic seduction of all times
but the genius of Lena's seven beauties
is that the film is not only absurd and
hilarious the deep seriousness of Nazi
quality is hauntingly chiseled into the
story not by the hero but by a secondary
character his cellmate Francesco it is
Francesco's brief flight for freedom his
inability to accept survival amid such
depravity that I have not been able to
forget these 40 years work Miller tells
a heart-stopping truth with a character
of no values no virtues it's this
reversal of expectation that makes seven
beauties so powerful so surprising and
so important and one of the best films
of the 20th century on a person
on a personal note I have to thank you
Lena you are literally my teacher I am
sure you don't know but I was a student
at the Australian film and television
score when you came to visit us in our
old toothpaste Factory in Sydney I was
riveted when you answered one students
plaintive question as to how you get the
money to make films it seems so hard she
said and youths Natalie replied you beg
you borrow steal you do whatever is
needed and what I understood was it's
hard as hell but you have to come at it
with unstoppable passion energy and
belief Lena you are a film warrior an
artist who is brave and brilliant I
congratulate the Academy for their
choice and you too Cara magnifica Lena
Tiana B bellezza a kraji o gratia gratia
grazie
oh yeah
[Applause]